I got some photo paper backdrops and
clearly I haven't figured out the
dimensions of everything yet so this is
a fun experiment
I just crooked hi my name is drew
telling Jen oh no you know you're like
it's different now it is Friday here on
my youtube channel which means I decided
to commit to commenting on your comments
so let's do that let's see what you
dumbasses had to say about my dumbass
content start over on Graham the place
for pictures and stories and words ding
dang doodle new very new producers and
probably did you not know when a new
person coming someone my social media
platforms i greased the crap of them and
welcome to this great family I used to
hate people but now I great people
because what do you mean when you can be
dumb how do I know that's a new person I
don't know I just get aka everyone's a
new person that's a long ass be also the
phrase long ass has been quite hilarious
to me imagine a long ass like just take
a second and you're branded imagine a
long ass like a dr. Seuss like long
extended ass after my brains out today
okay ding dang boozled more like ding
dong ding dong oh yes you are
ding dong you've been great I'm always
holding on to my butthole so joke on you
[Music]
but hey but paint what happened where am
i what how does this yellow get here
early plays plays more like Harley don't
play please stop playing video game
complete disclose more photos and videos
of your dog's name a cookie
Abraham's [ __ ] and they're just the
cutest thing in the world deduce from
that whatever you will you got a cute
Josie you've accrued lays it up grace
thanks charlie I know I can always count
on you
for the aggressive drug-related holiday
support comment oh how are you
I miss you when are you coming out to
Los Angeles can we hang out we'll take
this offline Nancy Clark can see Clark
more like fancy park benches with the
realtor act on it like booth actually
sat on the park bench looked at
Stephanie Shabbos or something is that a
real person and then call the phone
number being my paw and I've been
homeless on this apartment for so long I
should get myself a home oh there you
are human would me me big boy you've
some sort of disability in which you
transcribe into Instagram comments your
open dialogue during sexual endeavors
but yes I'm glad someone finally
recognized that I'm a big boy I let see
a one-time pilot bahama more like here's
a pilot for you great Toby the TV show
Cooper gross is she melting hearts now
let's go tutorial us to place we're also
pictures and words and storytelling but
just in a much more limited version
isn't it fun Joanna Brownlee no you were
sitting on a bromley more like Sona Bros
only sounds like hell on earth to me
you're been great at heart so I found a
place you can feel at home perfect place
for snapchatting sprouts thank you for
this Shawna this is really a grapevine
Basin follow me on snapchat or Instagram
story while I was on vacation for the
last two weeks you missed the journey of
the sprout I would say you really missed
out but I will say you really miss
sprout Capshaw new boomers new baby
Capshaw more like human grows OMG grace
Helbig mametown heart oh and Gilly or
shooting hashtag secret project and I'm
praying they are related well there's
only one way to find out cut to teracle
slightly relevant
definitely out of your age range for
associative joke
more Eclipse you are not you are not
[Music]
visual humor but calendars here more
like michael am Michael likes the
mornings and nobody likes mindful you're
look great two gigs of great topic
podcast on my phone should I delete them
or clear my camera roll hm I hope hm
gets back to you and lets you know what
you should do and I hope he says that
you should delete all of your photos and
just continue to download my podcast
because pictures worth a thousand words
and there are like probably a million
words in every podcast so my face 35 new
party person from annoyed face 35 more
like oh we're all gonna die someday 24/7
Grubin group didn't know what to make
for lunch today so thanks oh my god you
make kitchen pops up Ivan they look
beautiful house they K don't answer that
you're probably not even watching this
isn't Cherie still just sprays out on
your toilet so thank you know so -
usually well that's the place for moving
pictures and words and storytelling and
as long as you want it to be mental
patient six core Newburyport
environmental patient six four more like
metal patients six nine that's in
someone is having a really difficult
time getting a chastity belt off your
work if it isn't all wonky boobs here
kate girl you bring your expertise a
girl more like that sounds like so
really sad superhero there were like
Caitlin what do you want your superhero
tip you can be anything in the entire
world
Kate girls okay
Kaitlyn's gonna be an accountant you're
the bird wait wait wait wait wait your
than years ago I used to watch all three
of them and then I like stop for some
reason and I'm just starting to watch
again did they get married comment from
the video that I shot with Hannah and
mamrie looking at her old Instagram
photos no sin no marriage that has
happened but I love / hate that you type
out the word light but I can't judge
because I just spoke the word / DJ can
come to her new birth new birdie jet can
feel more like DJ can't though he is
trying so much everyone's a DJ if they
have hands that can push the button
Subaru's i'm way too stoned to watch
this because I feel like grace is Loki
making fun of me for help I am I hate
myself okay that's it for commenting or
comment so guys I hope you enjoyed this
video if you did give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to this YouTube channel to
make videos every Monday Wednesday and
Friday
sometimes if only on all social media
accurate so like across the board and
I'm going to work done we'll figure this
out let me know if you like this you
guys safe aside you'll tell me either
way and I just appreciate your attention
I don't know Samantha Hendershot newport
news for you mr. Hendershot more like
Samantha hand her a shot me meanie big
boy ever grace that exact Brenda for
cheese ravioli is currently in my fridge
not a STONER just a tired college
student proud of you give me that shot
please